so tell me about cuddle sanctuary cuddle
sanctuary is a social experience that
welcomes healthy human touch I associate
cuddling with sex like I don't know how
you separate it if you feel some arousal
coming on just shift your position what
if I when I shift I go like oh this is
how I shift oh so I'm gonna try a class
okay let's do it let's cuddle so let's
talk about the many different options of
things you can try the first one would
be spooning does anybody feel like
demoing the spoon you're in you're in
coming in for a landing is this
missionary of cuddling the only problem
I'm really having is it I'm concerned
where my phone is
might have I check my email bro um yes
now that I can't check my email I just
want to let you know the rest of the
time I'm gonna be thinking about
checking my email the next option that
you have prepared practice is called
companioning I guess I'm just gonna go
ahead sit next to you cool that's it um
this is it yeah in seventh grade this
would have blown my mind dude back to
back like I could just spin around and
then sort of let's do it and this is
kind of it all right it's just sort of
like a way for people like chill out and
talk it's very uh Fault in Our Stars
so I'm going away this summer do you
think we'll keep in touch yeah I don't
want to go what if he meets some other
girl then it's over
Oh crazy is that good is that what we
talk about like things like that yeah
well still think I'm on my phone
you're like the teddy bear I always
wanted you wanted a bi-racial yeah
Paulie our murse teddy bear with screwed
not your belt I'm not wearing a belt not
like a button no they're they're just
pajamas oh my god I love this
but I do want to feel how often do you
so much
that's this isn't right really the place
for that your pajamas tell me otherwise
will you read me my emails dear beloved
friend permit me my desire to go into
business relationship with you I am
daughter of late Elva diaries of Libya
whom was murdered during the recent
civil war in Libya before his death my
late father was a strong supporter
remember would you like to hold hands
with me and I gaze what are your
intentions with me I don't know I'm just
like lost anger I say just like I feel
like I'm like staying at the universe
the universe a little much yeah you
should follow me an Instagram all right
how's it that means a lot that you said
that
yeah
thanks for next I get lucky it's really
nice let me see thank you for having me
you guys
I seriously get what you're saying now
this isn't about sex at all I don't want
to have sex with any of you like when
are we gonna seriously hey this is Nikki
Glaser and this is the part of the video
where I tell you to watch more of my
videos but I'm not gonna tell you what
to do instead I'm just gonna look at you
judging Lee